uh now before the conservative party
leadership has started the name kemi
badenock was perhaps rarely suggested as
someone likely to replace boris johnson
as prime minister and yet the saffron
walden mp is proving her popularity
among party members she certainly
secured some high-profile backers
including michael gove and she hasn't
shied away from stepping into the
culture wars questioning her rival penny
mordance account of her position when
she was minister for women and
equalities
we can now talk to our next guest who is
lee rowley her campaign uh manager thank
you very much for being uh with us on
the programme today
i think it is fair to say that you know
most of our viewers may not have heard
the name kevin batenock before this
contest began
prime minister isn't an entry-level job
what was the main senior job that she
held in
held in government so until last week
she was a minister of state in the local
government department she's held a
number of jobs a number of different
departments including treasury she's had
the equalities brief she's done some big
jobs admittedly not in cabinet but big
jobs over the last three years and she's
done them well it's not just about the
job you have it's about what you do with
it and the one thing kemi has done over
the last three years taking on
particularly equalities brief for
example demonstrates she's willing to
take on people who don't necessarily
agree with her she's willing to stake
clear views and she's willing to do so
at the same time though
this isn't an audition for opposition
leader right the person who wins this is
going to be the next prime minister and
are there any concerns that you have
about whether someone who's most highest
level of experience they've had as a
minister of state is really ready to get
the keys of downing street if i had
concerns i wouldn't be here sophie this
morning i mean i if you look at what
kemi has done over three years she's had
some big jobs in government she's taken
on some difficult briefs she's done some
big things with them some things which
are challenging like what but in terms
of equalities there's a very very
sensitive debate around that around what
you do with against racism how you make
sure that discrimination isn't around
she went and brought forward the uh the
commission on on racial disparity she's
actually trying to get the root causes
of some of those issues against a huge
amount of opposition but if you look at
kenny compared to say david cameron zero
ministerial uh experience but he was
opposition leader this is the difference
he was elected to leadership he had not
spent a day in ministerial office before
he became prime minister in 2010 he'd
not taken a single decision as a
minister tony blair had not taken a
single day absolutely he's done that i
accept that and i also accept that there
is perhaps some you know sexism in the
way that we talk about a woman uh
compared to the experience of
david cameron george osborne tony blair
but but the question is the fact that
this is literally going into the job of
prime minister absolutely and as i say
lots of ministerial experience has more
ministerial experience than some of the
people who by common consent have been
very big figures in our political system
over the past 20 years and i think you
know the public are looking for
something different so if you are
looking for something different what
kemi offers is both the ability to
change the ability to say actually we've
done some things with lots of things
well over the last 12 years but we need
to do something different now
we have some experience what
specifically would she cut well she's
going to set some more out of that in
the coming in the coming days but she's
already talked about how we need to look
at university courses because there are
some university courses which perhaps
don't require public subsidy she's
talked about 300 billion pounds worth of
public money taxpayer subsidy which is
good which is spent every year by the
government in procuring services she
wants to look at doing that better and
she also wants to look all across
government
that everyone talks about the reason why
people talk about it and it doesn't get
delivered is because you don't go to the
root causes of the issues i have seen
far too much government by press release
when i've both been a minister and when
i've been an mp and the difference
between kemi and what's happened before
under all parties is that kemi is
actually saying we need to go to the
root cause of an issue work out what the
problem is and then try and come forward
with some she's obviously talked a lot
about the trans debate and penny
mordant's position on trans right when
she was a qualities minister um kemi
fedor told the sunday times today i'm
not going to call her a liar i think
it's very possible she genuinely did not
understand what she was signing off
i'm not sure what's worse being called a
lion or liar or saying you didn't
understand it well
what kenny is saying is this is a very
and if you go further down the sunday
times article kevin's saying this is a
very very difficult issue with some very
very entrenched views on both sides it
needs to be handled sensitively penny
has a set of questions to answer she i
don't think she really answered those
particularly well in debate on sunday on
friday we'll see whether she does
tonight because either
penny
did agree with self id and is now saying
that she didn't question why or penny
didn't agree with self id but it looks
as though the government decided to go
ahead with the the civil service and the
government and the department decided to
do it anyway question how did she let
that happen one of those two questions
that he's answering by penny and i look
forward to her doing so later and
baroness williams who worked in the
department at the time has hit out today
about what she describes as factually
incorrect representations put forward by
leadership candidates and she said that
she's shocked to see such incorrect
briefings do you think that this is
really getting into the into the realms
of mudslinging here well penny just
needs to clear up the point either she
didn't agree with self id
at the time and therefore she allowed
the civil service to do something else
question was that the right thing for a
minister to do or she did agree with
self id and now she's saying she didn't
she can clear it up today if she wants
to well she well she i'm she will be
speaking today obviously and but it does
feel let's move on to other
uh issues uh shall we there's been a lot
on trans rights so far as well um i want
to talk a little bit about um kevin
bateman's position in the race because
it felt like you know she was kind of a
big outsider she's obviously
outperformed many people's expectations
conservative home uh pole out today
which i think we can have another look
at
worth saying that this is unweighted and
so you know there are questions about
that but kemi beijing up there
um published july the 14th clearly out
in front
um
do you think that she could make the
final team
yeah i do we're here to make the final
suit kemi is absolutely in it to win i
mean this leadership campaign i think is
now nine or ten days old and kemi
decided to run last week talking to a
group of us because she thinks she's got
something to say and she wants to try
and change the country and what i think
this is showing and as you say it's a
snapshot but i think it's an important
snapshot it's saying that members of the
conservative party want kemi in the
final two and want that debate to happen
over the next six weeks about where the
party is going but more importantly
where the country needs to go i mean
cyril braverman another candidate of the
right of the party was eliminated on
thursday
she backlist trusts
were you disappointed not to get her
support well we're fighting for every
every every every colleague support i'll
be on the phones later talking to
colleagues to try and convince people
that kemi is the right person and we're
getting some really good feedback on
that specifically
so well there's a friend she's a friend
of kemmies people have to make their own
decisions i mean you can't you can't
make half a decision suella's made the
decision she's written about that today
but i disagree with her and i disagree
that's why i didn't join her campaign in
the first place so i didn't absolutely
agree with some of the things she was
saying but that's part of the debate and
it's why i'm absolutely committed to
getting kevin into the final two as much
as i can do and then kenny can make her
case to the members and then in times
the british people as prime minister
i'm quite intrigued about where kemi
boyd baden knocks support could go if
she is knocked out i know that you're
going to say we're fighting to the final
two we wanted to get to the next prime
minister but there is obviously a chance
that she is eliminated in one of the
earlier rounds you know some would like
to see her throw her weight behind liz
trust we've heard lord frost say that
for example
but there are rumors that actually she
may be more likely to roll in behind
rishi sunak well you're absolutely right
i'm going to say that kemi is in it to
win it because she is because
we said to kemi when a group of us when
kenny was saying that she thought she
was thinking about doing this we said if
you're going to do it do it to win and
we'll back you and that's why i'm here
today and it's why i've been trying to
help on the campaign for the last 10
days she is really serious about this
there is so many issues in our country
we've got to change it and my personal
view is we've got to change it with a
fresh start the um i guess one of the
conspiracies being the rounds in
westminster is michael gove her perhaps
most high-profile backer is doing this
as a way to help rishi sunak into number
10 but perhaps without getting his
fingerprints on it is it black ops there
for michael gove you think
i just don't know where some of this
stuff comes from i've been an mp for
five years this place just goes round
and round and round in some very strange
places sometimes kemi is in it to win
she wants to be prime minister she's
looking forward to changing the country
and that's why i'm backing it i really
hope she has the opportunity to do that
okay thank you very much uh lee rowley
there the campaign manager for kemi
pedernock